aujourd'hui pour toi c'est vraiment
situation galère mais 6 500 euros par
mois je pense que je suis choqué
ce sont plusieurs centaines d'étudiants
qui encore ce soir vont devoir
bénéficier d'une distribution
alimentaire de solidarité pour subvenir
à leurs besoins avant le 2è confinement
en septembre dernier c'était 200
bénéficiaires à chaque distribution
aujourd'hui on est à 5 cents
[Musique]
e
c'est la première fois que je viens
paris pose des tubes et donc c'est pas
du tout facile pour les étudiants et
j'ai vu ça du tout
ici c'est bon ça
tu l'as vu là maintenant c'est ça alors
attention il faut s'inscrire parce que
j'en ai pas eu d'annoncé sur inscription
peut-être qu on verra s'il ya des choses
en plus fabuleux là ils étaient venus
quand les règles
au féminin
je n'ai songé
manger c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on attend un peu pour la
suite du gouvernement notamment parce
que c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les
mesures qui ont été mises en place et on
voit que ça a pas l'air de suffire vu
simplement pas de personnes qui sont
autant de gouvernement je pense que
compétent pour le dire mais un peu plus
de sa jeunesse en sacrifice pour sa
jeunesse
merci bilal puis bon courage
enfin si on imagine aussi que la diffuse
la difficulté aussi psychologique c'est
dans ces événements par oui mais après
mais cette fois ci pour moi je prends
ton bois pour certaines personnes je
pense que c'est beaucoup
au niveau mental et psychologique
là
vous avez vu la situation se dégrader au
fur et à mesure des derniers mois j'ai
dit bien financière psychologique
[Musique]
ça c'est une sensation
les personnes lcd vraiment pièce et que
des signes dans super de mormal il y
aurait eu les fêtes soirée je réponds
gaza de même pour simplement d'avoir
cours présentiels seulement proche des
gens ma classe
la prochaine c'est pas comme si on
allait en présentiel ont vraiment rien
et après si nancy est pendant les fêtes
mais sans ballon
[Musique]